alzheimer's disease is the sixth leading
cause of death in the u.s
with more than 120 000 deaths in 2018.
millions of people over age 65 suffer
from loss of memory and dementia that
comes with the disease
causing anguish among family members and
creating a huge financial burden on the
health care system
as the u.s population ages the
alzheimer's foundation
estimates the number of people with
alzheimer's
will increase 22 percent by 2025
to 7.1 million against this grim
backdrop biogen's new alzheimer's drug
add you can umab
may be a welcome addition to the small
number of drugs used to treat the
disease
they will have the opportunity and
potential and to access something that
could change
their life the federal food and drug
administration approved the drug
on monday the drug is administered
intravenously
each month to patients in the early
stages of alzheimer's
adeukanumab is not described as a cure
but its manufacturer claims it slows the
progression of alzheimer's
by removing deposits called amyloid
plaques
that interfere in brain function in
alzheimer's patients
by clearing out this protein we seem to
have
sort of a reduction in the progression
of the disease
but does it really work some experts say
the evidence is lacking
the manufacturer conducted two
randomized
trials one was negative that is one
failed
and one was partially positive that is
the drug appeared to have a modest
effect
in one group of patients that received
it in that second trial
so we're left with a negative trial and
a partially successful trial and i think
the question that the fda has had to
grapple with is
what do you do with that there are also
concerns about side effects
in as many as a third of patients that
receive a high dose of this product
individuals develop brain swelling still
alzheimer's patients like ron deshaunt
who participated in clinical trials
says he is heartened by the prospect of
a new treatment
i would think there's a lot of other
patients like me that say the same thing
like let's yes get it on it we'll take
the
you know if it's not a hundred percent
i'll take the two and i'll take
the other percent and see if this could
help us hopes
and doubts about a new weapon against a
cruel affliction
rob reynolds al jazeera okay